here I'm crazy the fall opens up the
space for the
[Music]
good should we give up on the idea of
humans being either inherently good or
evil
yes well there we
go you are saying this as a
chrisan we'll get there we'll get there
Sor this is the pitch this is just the
pitch
I'm saying we should give up on the idea
that human beings are essentially good
or essentially evil because I can't give
any sense to that question to be honest
human beings are damaged changeable
vulnerable capable incapable where along
that Spectrum we place ourselves or
anyone else is one of the biggest
cultural and ethical issues we could
possibly be concerned with but we're
always reaching for apparently simple
answers to questions about human nature
which almost any available answer is
going to be not just unhelpful with but
possibly destructive so the short answer
is no we should not think of human
beings as essentially this or that we
shouldn't give up on the categories of
Good and Evil more on that later we
should think what it might be to look at
ourselves and one another
as well sites places where very
different things on fold and I hope the
unfolding will be part of this
conversation thank you very much um Ria
uh should we give up on the idea of
human beings either being inherently
good or evil I agree I think um we
should give up on that idea because if
we were inherently one or the other then
the idea that there is such a thing as
um improvement in our moral lives would
make no sense and yet we do strive we
often fail but also we often succeed in
becoming better as individuals
and so if there is such a thing as moral
progress then that means that there is
no inherent um good or evil in humans
and um what I want to contribute today
to the debate as a philosopher is to
instead of trying to categorize all
humans in such a generalized manner
whether they're good or evil is to think
of good and evil as conceptual
Frameworks and um think of what these
Concepts do for our lives and for the
way we understand morality thank you so
much Richard over to
you well I'm not sure if I agree or
disagree um with so far so um I I guess
what I I think is that um we need to
Define evil uh as something like acts of
intentional violence or which we
disapprove uh in other words evil is not
a a natural category it is a category
that is uh brought to us through social
action uh we need to have a social
decision about what is evil and what is
what is is not evil and uh in this um
I'm I'm bound to bring up the fact that
almost all killing is done in the name
of morality yeah uh somebody thinks that
it is a moral thing to do and someone on
the other side thinks it's not a moral
thing to do whether it's you're talking
about honor killings or or War uh in
defense of your uh your
country so I just want you know
emphasize that that evil is relative but
having said that it seems to me that we
should definitely think of both goodness
and evil as things that are inherently
associated with our
species uh I think that it would be uh
burying our heads in the sand to think
that evil is not a characteristic of the
human species as a whole I think also
it's characteristic of some individuals
some
Psychopaths but uh not all individuals
at all and it's certainly characteristic
of some uh ideologies so we have to
unpack it in in sightly complex ways but
uh but I want to insist that uh that
humans are uh have an inherent potential
for evil uh from the perspective of the
people who we might find ourselves
killing thank you very much slavo should
we give up on the ideas of human either
being inherently good or
evil I it looks as me who is usually
dismissed as a vulgar materialist I'm
here tempted to Advocate a more
fundamentalist even Christian St I'm an
atheist Christian which would say what
we understand as evil basically is I
would like to connect with what ran said
how human beings are basically damaged
vulnerable and so on and so on so for me
the only consistent answer a very
materialist one uh to how did we become
human is that at our level of animal
life something went terribly wrong and
then as a reaction to this to patch up
this leg we culture emerged so what I
would have uh what I have said is that I
also deeply agree with your point that
uh that uh uh evil fundamental and you
know what's my point uh my materialist
heelan reading of evil in Christian
terms the fall I think here I'm crazy
the fall opens up the space for the good
before the fall there is no good because
fall is more for me not simply fall into
sin fall is uh fall from some organic
immediate Unity into this vulnerable
open State and it's incidentally to make
Hegel actual in a wonderful very
materialist way heel in his anthropology
the beginning of third part of
Encyclopedia pedia is more intelligent
than Michelle Fuko where he says that
the first stage of being human is
madness we are animals which got lost no
instinctual compass and so on and then
to control this potential evil we built
civilization so I think that yes I
totally agree cultur is contingent
socially and so on and so on but you
have to presuppose that this is always
against a background of a certain
fundamental disorientation loss which
defines human species so no no good
without evil and I think if you think
you can have good without po evil
potential you end up doing real evil
what you brought out this is absolutely
crucial that
no Nazi killers and so on they are not
this demoniac romantic evil no they are
guys who simply think they are doing the
the greatest self saiz good for their
own narrow group and so on and so on
sorry thank you very much we are
definitely coming back to that um in
fact our first theme that we are going
to explore is are good and evil
objective are they objective categories
or are they categories that we've made
up to make sense of ourselves and I'm
going to throw to you Richard to open up
for us on that well uh pursuing my my
previous comments I absolutely do not
think that they are objective com uh
categories at all they are moral
categories
uh and so the origin of good and evil
can be seen as um the origin of the
sense of right and wrong uh the origin
of morality and and humans have a
morality of right and wrong that no
other species does we are unique in that
respect there's a kind of morality of
sympathy that uh that some some animals
can have for each other uh but a
morality that says this is right and
this is wrong that doesn't exist outside
US and and I actually think that uh
there's a pretty persuasive argument
that we can work out when the morality
uh of fairness that humans are
characterized by began uh and uh if we
had longer I would say it is 300,000
years ago that you know there's there's
a some point at which coincides with the
origin of homo sapiens uh that um our
lives changed and we developed a sense
of right and wrong and why was that it
was because Society changed changed in
such a way that there became a dominant
Alliance in society made up I think of
males uh who were able to impose what
they considered right and wrong and at
that point good became a category of
things that are in line with conform to
the um the motivations and wishes of the
dominant Alliance they were able to
impose this because they had had the
power of executing anybody in the group
and evil became things that are not in
line with the dominant power in the
group so a very uh relativistic
subjective concept of Good and Evil
thank you Richard I I think that might
be a good place to bring you in ran on
um I'm I'm I'm guessing maybe you don't
agree that good and evil don't exist
outside of ourselves but yes going out
on a limb yeah but that's a very
accurate yes um I think there's a
possible confusion here there's there's
certainly a story to be told of how
concepts of Good and Evil emerge how
concepts of right and wrong emerge but I
think that what Richard has just
outlined is to my mind
reductive in
that good and
evil are not
simply about power as those Concepts
have evolved over the Millennia and I
don't think we can now reduce them
simply to contests of power
if they were all just about who has the
right to the power of life and death
then I don't think it would ever
be imaginable that people could say it
is good to resist but it is good to
resist is one of the things that's been
associated with an ethical standpoint
ever since people have started talking
about ethics whether you go back to
classical tragedy or to Hebrew Christian
scripture or whatever it is good to
resist where's that from now that's just
one of the things I I would find awkward
about the a deep resentment about the
power exerted at their expense but if
you say it is good to resist not simply
it is um imperative I feel I must resist
but there is something to which the
powerful should be accountable which is
not currently at work oh well I mean the
way I would think about it is that uh
those who are saying it's good to resist
are shifting their moral framework from
the dominant power in the group to the
group of
resistors so the dominant power in the
overall group does not in fact have an
absolute control of the notion of
good that's right absolutely well I oh
yeah it's a contest let's bring contest
among power groups uh let's bring re in
on this maybe you can help us understand
these categories constructed categories
useful categories I I think that the
this distinction between subjective and
objective should be approached with
great caution and I think is problematic
because it suggests that moral
categories are not as real or as binding
because they originate in our practices
or language but the fact I think that
moral judgments are not objective in the
way that truths of physics are are held
to be does not make them subjective uh
nor does it diminish the authority of
those judgments so I think good and evil
are indeed human categories that we made
uh to make sense of ourselves and they
are objective and by objective I mean
that they are something that we canot
offer definitions for good or bad
definitions and something we can reason
about um but objectivity cannot be
detached from you know our history and
our practices I want however to add
something which I hope can kind of cut
through this problematic
distinction and that's an idea that I'm
very fond of the idea that goodness has
a special link to realism or to reality
and that's an idea that has recently
become more prominent thanks to work the
works of uh philosophers like Simon ve
Iris Murdoch and more recently cor
Diamond who link goodness to successful
perception Vil calls it attention and
she says that love is the highest form
of attention and Murdo argues that being
good allows us to look at reality more
objectively so this is a view we already
find in Plato uh when he Likens the good
to the Sun that is something very
Illuminating so how how can we think of
this connection between being good and
seeing clearly or or in a way that is
realistic I think there are many ways
but one way I want to suggest is that
when we try and perceive a situation
clearly uh what we need to do is give
our full attention to the situation and
often especially when there are certain
vices involved like for example Envy or
vanity our focus is too much on our own
selves and that way you can't see the
situation clearly so that's a way to
understand how being good can actually
give you it's not just objective but it
gives you access to reality in a kind of
privileged way and I find that very
interesting thank you very much SL uh my
God uh it's complex because I agree and
disagree with almost all of you my uh my
problem is first I agree with this that
today it's put as in the conflict
between those advocates for whom sex is
natural and LGBT and so on first I don't
think that this distinction is clear
between to put it vulgarly nature and
culture let's take sexual identity how
you identify I agree with
uh LGBT people and so on that it's not
immediately given you can culturally
identify as a woman man trans and it
cannot be deduced from your biological
identity but at the same time
I don't think as sometimes they put it
that it's simply a matter of personal
choice I feel a woman I feel a man or
whatever I think that there is and the
same goes for me then with the problem
good in evil it's not if we say it's
socially determined and it is it doesn't
simply mean it's arbitrary and
subjective in this narrow sense I would
like to Advocate this Paradox that
fundamental decisions are unconscious I
repeat always this part I'm sorry in the
sense of yes it is
contingent but you are never in a
position external position to choose
it's like you mentioned love falling in
love you never look at it okay I want to
fall in love you are beautiful you you
let me compare your features no falling
in love means and here I don't see
clearly your point on Clarity falling in
love means for me something a great
exclusion you not only see things
clearly but my cynical mind to see
something things clearly there are many
other things that unconsciously you
choose not to see clearly like we as a
civilization only now we're becoming
whereare we decided what happens to pigs
to chicken and so on an immense amount
of suffering we were taught to really to
Simply uh ignore that or again falling
in love you never fall in love all of a
sudden you realize that you are in love
and I think it's the same with religious
identity it's an obscenity as kagar knew
it clearly to say I was reading Jewish
text Christian text and whatever
Buddhist text and my God I found the uh
the the arguments for Christianity the
best now kagar answers to see the
arguments for Christianity you already
have to believe at some level to
continue watching this video click the
link in the top left or in the
description below or visit I a.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas